[Musique]
je
au lendemain de sa victoire à l'émission
canada's got talent la chanteuse jeanick
fournier sa volée demande ce qui lui
arrive je me suis dis personne méchant
tu as l'opportunité d'être là pour faire
de chaque seconde rampe et de bien
l'action goffart et de voir mon but
yohann à sienne avant moi plus avec
quelques années la famille je me disais
pense pas non plus que samantha who were
personnes ont eu lieu lors on peut
tracer sa
pop et chantent des chants
[Applaudissements]
sa prestation a fait vivre de grandes
émotions à sa famille réunie au lac
saint jean c'était un ancien de fleurs
c'est tellement mentionna
[Musique]
l'artiste se démarque depuis de
nombreuses années sur les scènes de la
région dans différentes productions ça
doit pas arriver de meilleures personnes
jeunes etc c'est un peu c'est une grande
voix c'est une bonne personne c'est une
grande dame de la chanson plus elle
mérite tout ce qui lui arrive une voix
puissante et un coeur immense depuis
près d'une quinzaine d'années jeanick
fournier est préposée aux bénéficiaires
à la maison de soins palliatifs du
saguenay elle est reconnue pour son
dévouement sa bonne humeur et sa
bienveillance ses collègues ont suivi la
finale avec beaucoup d'intérêt mais moi
j'ai eu la chance de l'écouter ici je
l'écouté dans la chambre d'un patient
avec un battage travaillait avec une
préposée une collègue mais qu'on
l'écouté avec impatience et on criait
grillet quand j'ai vu que c'est elle qui
était la grande gagnante a vraiment
content pourrir là vraiment un gros
bravo
à quelques jours de son 50e anniversaire
cette aventure marque un tournant dans
sa carrière et dans sa vie ce que je
partais je le surveillais avec mon
amoureux j'ai dirigé par une canne aux
catalans tué jésus
150 mille dollars tu comprends je vis
dans un petit 4 et demi dans une
merveille opérative h route mais
je veux offrir
deux chars ma maison je je je je veux
plus vivre ça je peux qu'on serait
plaint que je suis quand sa tête pour ça
je veux tu chanter aimer donner vivre
avec mais bokoko d'amour ma famille mes
amis tout le temps profitez tout ça
ici julie larouche sera du canada
saguenay